on
connaît ces villes à la ceni en tant que
chanteur à l'eurovision 2010 9 buts el
hassani en tant que danseur lors de la
dixième saison de danse avec les stars
qui vient de se terminer merci beaucoup
quand on connaît désormais bilal assadi
en représentation divine faisant la une
du magazine lgbt têtu depuis quelques
années le jeune homme fait parler de lui
et c'est bien pour ça qu'il a été élu
personnalité de l'année par le journal
je leur fais pourtant cette couverture
semble déjà faire polémique la société
média transports qui gère l'affichage de
la sncf et de la ratp aurait refusé
d'exposer le magazine dans ses stations
et s'égare dans nos contrats avec les
opérateurs de transport il nous est
impossible d'afficher des visuels où
sont présentes des références
religieuses une représentation qui selon
eux pourrait choquer les voyageurs alors
vidal hassani représenté en sorte de
christ comprenez vous que c'est une
puisse choquer
agir aussi merci gilles j -louis
guerrouj antoine gouy bilal assadi
représenté en une en une sorte de christ
comprenez vous le boycott de la fntr
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir la une à
chaque fois derrière moi merci françois
billot de lochner président de la
fondation service public
vous vous êtes catholique
traditionaliste proche des mouvements
radicaux ou que sais tu ne vous
dérangent
traditionalistes changeait rien
catholique oui oui d'accord mais il n'y
a pas de catholiques pour moi une x ou y
ait des catholiques d'accord très bien
bien alors c'est très bien que ça va
bien merci à la cour des comptes y
intéresser un lot dit qu'on n'était pas
bien le dire mais dès qu'on dit quand on
ajoutera 10 pour être pourquoi il ya des
cathos du voile à allah n'est pas pour
[Rires]
vous me demandez si ça me choque louis
françois et bien en tant que catholique
je vais vous dire très franchement
ça ne me choque même pas d'accord et
vous savez pourquoi parce que je trouve
ça tellement stupide que c'est pas
choquant c'est à dire voyez vous je
crois que ce qui peut choquer c'est
quand on a la volonté de nuire notamment
par exemple aux catholiques à un très
grand groupe de catholiques en lait
chaud quand par exemple le christ sur la
croix et une de charlie hebdo à elle
vous dérange absolument voir plus
profondément à la les unes des aliens au
son d'une stupidité ahurissante vraiment
je ne comprends même pas qu'on puisse
défendre les une de charlie hebdo celle
là font pas rire du tout pardon vous
font pas rire à moi ne me font pas rire
du tout du tout du tout et là vous voyez
vous on aurait eu le christ en croix par
exemple là j'aurais dit c'est vraiment
c'est satanique cet odieux c'est pervers
c'est cette atroce là je trouve ça
débile parce que ça rime à rien c'est
pas intelligent moi je trouve que tu es
tu que je connais par ailleurs parce
qu'ils m'ont déjà interviewé on n'est
pas tout à fait sur la même ligne soyons
clairs je trouve que ce sont des gens
respectables mais là je ne comprends pas
qu'ils fassent quelque chose qui
objectivement me paraît stupide voilà
est gelée chloriers plus intelligent
très souple et au guillaume genton vous
vous êtes le seul avec gilles que sa
dette fait dire oui parce que j'ai vu
beaucoup de gens sur les réseaux sociaux
des jacqueries l homophobie parce que
c'est bill année ça nique ont interdit
non pas du tout c'est juste que l'
agence de communication qui gère donc
ces publicités n'a pas le droit de
mettre en avant des affiches avec des
références religieuses première chose
ensuite il sous-entendre que ça puisse
choquer des voyageurs oui moi je
comprends que ça puisse choquer des
voyageurs pour moi c'est une sorte de
blasphème sert qu'on détourne des codes
de l'art
ça puisse choquer auprès des voyageurs
je pense qu'en faisant ça des tuiles ont
voulu faire une maille à thomas van pul
caricom a usé de rédacteur en chef de la
travers moi je pense que tu es tu oses
ont voulu faire un coup de comines une
un peu provoc c'est leur droit c'est
tout à fait leur droit et faut pas
s'étonner après que ça puisse choquer
devant et aurait déjà personnellement je
trouve là une très belle
elodie je la trouve magnifique la une
voilà je crains que la photo est
magnifique je trouve que les couleurs
sont magnifiques voilà je le dis même la
typo tout je trouve vraiment que la une
est très très belle voilà merci mme
colas en tout cas esthétiquement je
trouve ça magnifique que thomas
vanpouille rédacteur en chef de thé
tuque au fait c'est juste et je vous dit
bilal assadi à l'été il a été élu par
têtu personnalité de l'année j c'est
vrai que c'est le vent représenté comme
ça comment vous avez eu l'idée mais vous
savez c'est assez simple c'est les
brainstormings autour de la future une
comme on fait dans toutes les rédactions
là c'était un numéro de fin d'année
effectivement on avait décidé le nommé
personnalité de l'année donc en
naviguant sur les thèmes fin d'année on
voulait l'installer comme une icône est
donc assez vite arriver cette idée de la
madone de l'icône ce qui est un
classique 15 la culture pop madonna l'a
fait bien de celle a fait tout le monde
l'a fait je n'étais pas au but le but je
pense pas que c'était de choquer ah non
non battu chez
lui c'est ce que berné c'est pas
choquant franchement brent choses comme
celle du moulin en fait non elle est
très belle c'est vrai sur le fait qu'il
y ait des gens qui soient choqués par
une je lui ai toujours dit si je peux
comprendre parfois qui est des gens qui
sont choqués par d une qui soit voilà
comme une de charlie hebdo car je peux
au moins qu'il y ait donc ils soient
choqués mais là dessus franchement je ne
vois pas du tout où est le problème je
le rythme à le voir raison c'était
absolument pas le sujet monsieur ne
serait pas du tout choquée s'est elle
installée comme une icône
ils vont en plus bilal a ici s'y prêtent
vraiment parce qu'il ya cette ambiguïté
d'ailleurs au départ on était parti sur
la madone sur la représentation plutôt
de marie c'est plutôt ça avec la cie
quand en pop culture c'est vrai que
beaucoup l'ont pris pour jésus parce que
il ya cette ambiguïté qui finalement lui
va très bien mais on voit bien que toute
la nuit les belles sont sa position son
expression sont respectueuses et c'est
évidemment un
comment dire la religion catholique a
inventé des images a inventé cette
iconographie elle l'a fait d'ailleurs
puisque son imprègne pour con là pour
qu'on pour contre ça devienne un élément
de la culture populaire et donc c'est un
classique et la notion de blasphème elle
un peu gênante dans cette dans ce nom ce
débat comprenez vous comprenez pas la
décision de la ratp de la sncf qui a
refusé d'afficher la couverture cette
couverture dans les gares et stations
ils disent que le caractère
conventionnel de l'image pourrait
choquer une partie des voyages là
justement pas conventionnel
évidemment aucun caractère confessionnel
en fait la réaction évidemment on la
comprend pas à nous on voulait afficher
notre une seule campagne d'affichage
classique on la comprend d'autant paca
une cour il ya une confusion qu'on a
beaucoup dans les réactions il ya eu
quelques réactions négatives sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment de la part de
jeunes
je confonds de la fin qui nous a accusés
de blasphème et c'est intéressant c'est
cette idée parce que et c'est dommage
que d'ailleurs la ratp la régie des
transports médias transports le valide
parce que autant dans la religion dans
la religion musulmane ans et on n'a pas
le droit de représenter le prophète
mahomet c'est considéré comme un
blasphème par les croyants musulmans
dans la religion juive on n'a pas droit
de représenter dieu non plus est
considéré comme un blasphème dans la
région catholique ya pas de ça c'est
quand même important de le souligner
vous qui êtes là monsieur de rappeler
quand même notamment aux jeunes
personnes qui nous regardent et qui
peuvent avoir cette confusion que dans
la religion catholique il n'est
absolument pas interdit au contraire
puisque c'est la religion catholique
talent même si inventer toutes ces
icônes enfin ce qu'est ce que vous
répondez à je vous avais dit quelque
chose au tout début de ce que vous dites
est très très intéressant si vous avais
dit le mot vous même mais en fait vous
avez dit s'est introduit une confusion
lors je sais pas comment vous l'aviez
mais sa fusion entre marais et de nom
mais ce qui est intéressant c'est que
effectivement des jeunes générations à
la limite elles peuvent même ne pas très
bien comprendre même ne pas forcément
faire le lien moi ce que je trouve
extrêmement dommage et ça si elle est là
nous n'allons je suis pas du tout votre
avis ce n'est pas parce qu'une image est
très belle qu'elle est acceptable bon
qu'une image soit belle sait très bien
moi j'aime beaucoup la basse et j'ai une
passion pour les choses au clair en quoi
vos croyances vraiment non mais ce qu'on
se serait dit on non je trouve que
l'ambiguïté qui consiste en fait à quoi
fait finalement d'une espèce d'auriol
religieuse le christ derrière cette
étude je suis désolé mais bilal assadi
c'est sûrement une personnalité qui vous
plaît beaucoup elle peut ne pas plaire à
des centaines de millions de personnes
est-ce qu'il faut vraiment transformé
bin al hassani en ce costume dans cette
position et avec tout ce qui est de
sous-entendus derrière quand même oui
non
si on reprend l'imagerie qui est
parfaitement autorisé même par la
religion catholique criaient a dû
tourner en voir au blasphème qui encore
mais si tu confusion je ne dis pas que
c'est tu me lâches et matois je dis que
ça entretient de mon point de vue encore
il ya peut-être des catholiques qui vont
trouver ça très blasphématoire moi je
trouve que surtout et c'est pour ça que
je trouve ça un peu stupide pardonnez
moi parce que je trouve c'est un trône
et une confusion totalement inutile on
n'avait pas besoin de ça si vous voulez
vous auriez pu faire une photo j'allais
dire dans l'idéologie la philosophie
têtu qui aurait pu être splendide sans
être forcément le christ où la sainte
vierge derrière ça c'est simple je
trouve qu'on ait choisi gilbert dess
vous êtes vous êtes cheveux oui je suis
choqué comprenez le break tôt de la tête
je leur dis bravo à la sncf
pourquoi je leur dis bravo ça ce set au
mieux elle est magnifique et j'adore
bilal têtu c'est formidable c'est
magnifique mais je suis désolé ça ne va
pas de soi d'exposer sa dans une gare
dans une gare vous avez plein de gens de
tous les âges de toutes les confessions
de toutes les erreurs origine en quoi
ces six hier mais laissez moi finir qui
circulent dans la garde et cette une il
faut les expliciter je suis désolé a des
enfants à des jeunes il faut leur dire
ce que c'est c'est quand vous êtes dans
une gare nous avait autre chose à faire
que de dire ce que c'est donc pour moi
ça n'a rien à faire dans une gare même
si c'est magnifique ce l'action
s'effondre à une invasion là on entend
le voyageur ça me choque au dépassement
puissant qui
sait pas nager plus mais
on a le droit de voyager on a le droit
voyager et on a marre à s'interroger sur
mais je vous donne mon opinion sur tb
conover
s'interrogeant s'il vous plaît pas c'est
le prix laissant les plus intéressants
les gens aiment les intéressants vous
savez il y en a certains d'entre vous
qui peuvent tout de suite mais ce sera
dur a dit mme maillet non on n'en peut
plus de cette dictature et 11 ans et
c'est insupportable alors non seulement
elle est sublime votre une aile est
important parce que bilal c'est une
sorte de figure de proue aujourd'hui du
mouvement lgbt du harcèlement par
rapport au fait justement qu'il était
homosexuel et qu'il y en a beaucoup
souffert donc elle est hyper importante
et pardon monsieur mais vive le
blasphème on a grand black femmes non si
vous mais ces messieurs attendent la
drogue la salle droit oui on a bien su à
guardado dans le droit et c'est
magnifique et je m'insurge et je trouve
ça scandaleux que la fncf est là et la
ratp est interdit cette île on pas en
droit de faire une pub comme ça qu'est
selon
oscar de l'élitisme si on n'aime pas on
ne regarde pas à ben voilà voilà voilà
et moi je ferme les yeux
fermés les yeux maintenant et j'adore
ton deuxième annonce que je m'attendais
s'attaquent quant à doc à leur
porte-monnaie de mai prénommé 2 6 3
mais je trouve ça bien
c'est comment la réveiller
demandait depuis des années les annoncer
elle pense à lui atteint souvent ça
c'est vraiment mère d'henri iv kato
pelosi moi j'en peux plus être de sa
viabilisation par la vierge des
religions citoyens
s'il vous plaît
trouvez la lune que q moi j'ai une chose
complètement ce soit sur celle ci reçoit
tout à l'heure je ne parlais pas le
droit pardonnez moi mais je m'en fous
complètement là on est dans une notion
qui est vraiment une scion la grille
s'humanise d'intelligence de beaune est
restée je suis désolé mais par exemple
dans les kiosques à journaux on a des
images pédopornographiques y sont et
allez on va dire aux enfants attendait
les enfants ne regardez pas une image
pédopornographique et sur le kiosque à
journaux
je suis totalement d'accord avec
monsieur il ya des images qui peuvent
choquer les enfants qu'on ne peux pas
expliciter parce qu'on voyage habitation
la nation parce que vous parlez à
l'argile parler d'expliciter est
justement ya beaucoup de jeunes qui nous
regardent il faut faire attention à ça
entretenir cette confusion j'ai reçu pas
mal de messages et aussi le jeûne on
malaisie de jeunes musulmans qui disait
attention c'est la même chose qu'avec
mahomet etc c'est quand même important
que nous qui s'agitent mais oui mais
c'était important de le rappeler que non
et qu'il n'y a pas d' offense l'agencé
on peut la trouver qu clients qui la
trouve absolument pas d'offensé c'est
important de le rappeler non pas parce
que
non pas pour défendre tu es tu me
défendre moi mais parce que il ya
vraiment faim dans les réactions qu'on a
reçues il y avait vraiment cette
confusion qui était massif chez les
chers amis je serai prêt dit non je
serai patron de têtu je ferais mais je
sais qu'il n'y ait pas de confusion à
quoi sert-il aujourd'hui dans un monde
où la confusion est partout mais à
personne pourquoi mettre une confusion
oui
c'est moi j'ai dit françois cyril
hanouna a raison c'est l'image est belle
je suis totalement d'accord mais
pourquoi mettre de la confusion vous
auriez pu faire une image aussi et
peut-être plus bête sans confusion et
lâchement mois là tout aurait été pour
le mieux dans le meilleur des
mondes évidemment enquête en france mais
attendez si ça m'était figaro magazine
ça m'aurait gêné et autres et bien sûr
en fait évidemment il n'ya même pas de
débat si ce n'est que le figaro magazine
une différence est là je partage tout à
fait votre point de vue c'est que quand
on voyage bas et quand on voyage on
voyage on n'est pas là pour regarder si
j'achète le figaro magazine j'accepte
normalement le contenu donc et une
petite ambiguïté par rapport à ceux de
votre question si vous l'aimez
évidemment que dans le figaro magazine
sa mort est choquée parce que le figaro
magazine ça traîne sur les tables il
peut y avoir des enfants qui comprennent
pas je pense qu'ils seront pas là parce
qu'ils en feraient enquête sur là dessus
les suffixes de savannah sur un terrain
qui venait juste d'être certain
extrêmement sensible il faut en parler
avec beaucoup d'attention moi j'ai
introduit la notion de de bon goût la
notion d'esthétique axe coup les voilà
dans mais se voit alors moi
personnellement je suis moi je te
connais mais
il est choqué parce que je trouve que
c'est plutôt c'est beau voilà dix
garçons où contrairement à d'autres 4
amara d'autres comme spectateur et j'ai
fait l'objet de beaucoup de caricatures
je
ne sais pas
je te vends vraie tournée n'est pas du
tout aussi bons qu'eux ça va tuer
beaucoup moins bon en vrai que sur les
appareils que vous
la une de têtu d'aussi en christ un jour
mais bon par contre ce que je voulais
dire c'est effectivement le terrain est
extrêmement sensible et ce dès qu' il ne
faut pas perdre de vue que des cas les
captures aujourd'hui offense
profonde démarche
incertaine
si vous êtes un lecteur jugera yann
syriza c'est une caricature et cyril ont
du mal à vendre et la parole stone mais
sur la vie aux gens je ne suis
absolument pas heurter à accorder la
chute très belle mois le meurthe pas
d'accord je trouve qu'il ya une
différence avec d'autres crient accords
du lac y effectivement
conduit une dimension beaucoup plus
grave
ça va une comprenez vous le boycott de
la sncf oui à 80% mais alors voulu
rajouter avait quelque chose qu'on soit
ya un instant oui mais je ne sais plus
je voulais intervenir jusqu'à avait dit
ce charmant jeune homme mais j'ai
complètement mais c'est pas grave
c'était sympa de voir les vrais
confusion de quelle confusion ça pouvait
entraîner chez les jeunes l'idée de
cette une c'est quand même de montrer
qu'en fait on peut être soit quel que
soit son genre quelle que soit sa façon
de s'habiller quelle que soit sa façon
de s'exprimer c'était le message 2000 al
hassani c'est le message qu'il avantage
je suis aujourd'hui c'est fait et c'est
pour ça qu'on l'a placé en personnalité
de l'année c'est ça qu'ils disent est
une c'est une unique qui rassemble c'est
pas du tout une qui provoque alors alors
oui je manage à tahiti en fait du temps
la chimie lâcher on darlas je ne suis
pas du tout d'accord pardonnez moi avec
ce que voulait dire parce que on ne peut
pas assimiler si vous voulez en gros la
religion catholique à bilad hassani on
est sur tout autre chose s'il ya un fait
honnêtement aucun rapprochement si la
conclusion c'est que des gens peuvent le
prendre pour jésus a priori on essaie
alors mais là on compare les deux
auteurs la confusion vient pas là dessus
mais donc si vous voulez je j'insiste
lourdement sur le fait que vous pouviez
faire une très belle photo avec toutes
les possibilités
inouïes qu'on peut avoir aujourd'hui
pour que ce soit extrêmement séduisant
mais que ça ne représente pas forcément
une religion parce que à mon avis c'est
complètement inutile voilà c'est simple
mathieu tu comprends la décision de la
sncf et de la ratp non pas du tout
choquée par les propos de gilles et de
monsieur non seulement les cette une est
très belle esthétique non seulement ya
pas de blasphème mais ça va beaucoup
plus loin que ça elle montre la
progression de l'église catholique ce
qui est très intéressant très important
je rappelle que le pape françois s'est
prononcé en faveur de l'union civile
pour les homosexuels c'est une grande
première un sou jean paul ii encore pas
si longtemps il ne connaissait même pas
l'existence des homosexuels donc au
contraire je trouve que c'est une
avancée très intelligente c'est une très
belle et très intelligente très
progressiste et je suis mais tellement
choqué par le sondage que vient de voir
80 portant des gens qui sont choqués
parce que moi je ne peux pas je ne peux
pas ne pas corrélées le fait que les
gens qui sont choqués par cette une au
fond d'eux ils ne sont pas tout
simplement hausse il n'y a pas tout
simplement à roland d'homophobie
c'est dégueulasse
axel homophobes mois oui mais vous êtes
fous pourquoi c'est ça c'est des gaules
adam n'est pas ça du tout rassuré
est-ce que tu mettes à des gens qui me
paraît donc l'avoir bilal abou dhabi
pour présenter peut-être dans la vallée
ont
dépassé votre petite pensée pensée plus
grande rigueur non mais ça c'est des
gâteaux deux jours que je suis là pour
quoi c'est choquant pour quoi c'est
choquant parce que la religion pour moi
je vais vous le dire j'en ai marre vos
discours policé et moi j'avais toujours
pour moi c'est l'un team et j'en ai
marre qu'on explose la religion et j'en
ai marre je ne veux pas qu'on expose sa
dans les gares je ne veux pas d'image
religieux dans les gars je vous le dis
dans les gars on se transporte il ya
plein de gens on n'a pas à me poser de
la religion dans une gare c'est ça c'est
interdit l'actrice pose
madonna vous attend
si vous êtes un fidèle et c'était en
vérité
j'adore têtu arrêté
sur marketing parce que vous êtes
géniaux pour sa lettre
vous êtes fou quoi des cas tous les
propos que tu te le dise
ce qu'il
s'est passé j'ai le droit j'ai dit ce
que je ne rabats joie gil j étais pas
parce qu'on met la cc c'est dégueulasse
mais pas les sens on fume pas lui dire
ça y'a pas 80% des femmes continuent ce
que les suisses il a été par ce sondage
l'épousé quand je prends le train de
voir là une wheel assainir une de têtu
pour la religion catholique pardon à
100% avec mathieu merci à force de
lutter contre l'intolérance on devient
facile versées mais c'est très facile à
des idées qui sont graves mais alors
c'est dégueulasse thomas thomas on va se
calmer parce que thomas un petit peu de
douceur
et tout doux le magazine thomas vous
avez réussi votre cou et que c'est une
autre une fait en sorte que ce soit une
qui soit belle il arrive quelque chose
qu'il soit intelligent qui marque et qui
soit acheté une fille née pour que
l'ancien sous la vue parce que deere ce
derrière cette une on a quand même tout
un dossier sur le harcèlement scolaire
bien sûr que quel bilan
lutte avec nous on arrive dans plein de
contenus on a d'autres personnalités de
l'année qui ont été nommés à
dans le dossier voilà c'est l'idée c'est
quand même c'est un magazine et c'est
j'en parlais tout à l'heure à mathieu
parce qu'on est revenu aussi sur la
polémique sur est ce que bill à la sagne
et représentent les gays ou pas et on en
revient là dessus dans le magazine
l'idée c'est de faire un pont en fête
entre les gens on n'est pas là du tout
pour diviser les croyants des non
croyants les homos des noms un mot les
garçons virgin les garçons folle bilad
justement c'est ça qui l'incarnent hyper
bien et qui va incarner dans une
émission de populaire
c'est que justement enfin on n'a plus à
choisir aujourd'hui la représentation
gay elle est multiple lgbt elle est
multiple et donc bilal cantine quand il
fait ça danse mais la première manche
pas si vous soutenez la première manche
le tableau sur signal quand ils arrivent
et qui défoncent la porte sur le plateau
est qui et qui fait sa première dans ce
qui est extraordinaire d'ailleurs il l'a
refaite au dernier prime c'est ça qui
dit en fait c'est cette espèce de
libération quand même que mathieu
n'avait pas à son époque mais moi
j'avais pas à mon époque je suis entre
les deux est en fait aujourd'hui voilà
la représentation est légitime elle est
plurielle et en fait l'idée vous avez
reçu à nice le jeune qui avait été
agressée de 17 ans assureront
le message et s'adresse à ces jeunes là
leur dire qu'en fait
aujourd'hui il n'y a plus il n'ya plus
de ya plus de manières d'être un garçon
normal et plus manière d'être une fille
normale en fait on est comme on est le
garçon et yanis il avait agressé les
gars ça et même c'est même pas curité
savais même pas qu'il était homo la
question c'était césaire il avait des
airs de paix ddr efféminé et en fait là
on est là pour dire mais en fait tout ça
n'existe plus aujourd'hui et bilal
évidemment repousse ses frontières la
repousse ses limites là et monte sur tf1
à une heure d'émission familial que ces
barrières sont tombées sont en train de
tomber gilles ça va mieux ouais mais je
suis vraiment touchée par ce qu'a dit
mathieu franchement matthieu bazil
mais les combattre toute ma vie sans
vous
me taxez domo fox et vous j'ai retiré je
vous aime tellement que venant de vous
ça me blesse profonde
dimensions mentirai s'il vous plaît
d'abord pardon mais ses 45 ans moi je
suis en déplaise j'ai une croix ici je
suis catholique et guay voilà pendant 45
ans on a été on a été reconnu par
personne par aucune au glissement
personne peut même pas dans une église
la souffrance elle était là on appâte
qui a fait c'est formidable qui a sorti
une phrase alone qu'on n'est pas encore
là pas encore totalement vance et on a
un pape qui fait une avancée formidable
on a des magazines mais qui sont là
aussi pour que la progression avance
alors quand j'entends monsieur pardon
monsieur mais pour moi c'est un c'est un
autre âge c'est une autre génération et
quand je t'entends aussi dire on ne peut
pas m'imposer bilal dans une guerre
quand je prends le train part dont
gilles je ne peux rien retirer ce que
j'ai dit moi je voudrais simplement
intervenir parce que là on si vous
voulez je trouve qu'il est extrêmement
facile aujourd'hui de mettre le pape à
toutes les sauces
je suis désolé mais jusqu'à nouvel ordre
quand même il ya un certain nombre de
textes voilà qui ont été bâties tout au
long des siècles et qui sont toujours
valables aujourd'hui il ya texte que
vous connaissiez puisque vous êtes
catholique il appelle le catéchisme de
l'église catholique bon il a il a il
n'est pas vieux il a dit à 30 ans
baissaient cerutti renouvelée qui
remodela tous les 5 ou 10 ans sur tous
les sujets que vous évoquez l'église
catholique a des positions très fermes
très clair le pape a dit effectivement
une phrase point sur l'union l'union
civile oui qui n'est pas du tout une
reconnaissance de prime d'un mariage
c'est aussi qu à deux mondes différents
je suis en fait vous râlez du pape et
vous parlez de moi vous voyez ce que je
trouve ce que vous dit non mais ce que
je trouve c'est très très intéressant
c'est à dire que si je parle d'un
document et du pape vous dit tu es
homophobes vous dites il a vu c'est une
phrase c'est tout pas même important de
cette phrase héros caché n'est jamais
fixé le connais que deux ans au sénégal
doivent pouvoir se soutenir mais chez
rare non je n'ai jamais dit vous me
faites dire des choses vous dérange
cette phrase je suis en train de citer
une phrase bon voilà c'est tout je n'ai
jamais voté vous ai je la reprendre mais
on peut faire soyons mais attendez c'est
pas ça le sujet au plus c'est que
aujourd'hui moi je suis désolé françois
mieux le père le président de la
fondation de service politique on en a
rien à cirer moi ce qui compte c'est ce
que pense aujourd'hui le milliard deux
cents millions de catholiques
représentée par le parti sont
représentés par le pape et qu'ils ont
dans l'église leur mot à dire et qui ont
le droit d'avoir des usines et si vous
voulez et moi je comprends ça c'est même
phrase du patron je termine la partie je
peux tamim réseau mais je vais vous le
dire après je termine mon raisonnement
ça veut dire que par rapport à des
sujets comme ça l'église a des positions
les catholiques et 1 milliard 200 ou 300
millions de catholiques ils prennent des
positions ils sont plus ou moins en
accord avec la doctrine aujourd'hui on
sait qu'il ya beaucoup de cadeaux et qui
ne sont pas d'accord avec la doctrine
donc on voit que tout ça bouge
énormément mais je revendique le droit
je suis désolé et là je vais vous
choquer je revendique le droit d'être
libre de me dire sur l'homosexualité je
me pose un certain nombre de questions
sur j'ai le droit de le dire maintenant
sur la phrase du pape région l'union
civile si moi personnellement je trouve
que c'est une assez bonne idée parfait
autant je suis contre la loi taubira
c'est à dire le mariage parce que le
mariage est une institution qui a pour
but de protéger les enfants donc on est
dans un autre schéma est donc
personnellement la loi taubira ne
m'allait pas j'ai manifesté contre je
suis toujours contre bon on verra ce qui
va se passer elle va peut-être
maintenant durer pendant pendant l'ère
sinon j'ai bien ses membres sonnera
comme un clin d'oeil est une invite à
tous
je voyais vous simplement là où vraiment
et je suis partagent le même si on n'est
pas forcément d'accord sur surya mais le
le procès en homophobie est absolument
scandaleux il est absolument aberrant on
a le droit de dire
l'homosexualité ne pose un problème
c'est ma liberté la france est le
premier à dire j'étais content le
mariage est loin ce n'était pas un
problème
j'ai le droit d'en mais la liberté
d'expression je me sens totalement libre
de dire ce que je pense a fait alors pas
de façon émotionnelle et non mais voilà
parce que je travaille sur ces sujets là
et tu es tu m'a interviewé genre je vous
en parlais à l'instant sedan en 2018 bon
voilà on a eu un interview très long
très long voilà tout va bien on a le
droit de s'exprimer librement on a le
droit d'être contre têtu on à droite pas
d'accord avec ce que dit le journaliste
le journaliste dit dans un chapeau qu'il
trouve que ce que je dis est d'ailleurs
c'est la liberté donc laissez nous
libres je vous en supplie
on